traditional wife believes that family is
more important to spend her primary
reproductive years over a career over
anything really so essentially if you
spent the ages before 25 working a job
that's feminist that's what the elites
wanted if you have two kids that's
feminism why is having two kids feminine
because the elite the feminists want you
to spend your reproductive years working
instead of raising a family I'm not
saying I'm not saying you're a bad
person if you chose to do this but when
you think about it how would you get two
kids how if you're fertile from the age
of 16 to the age of 35. that's 20 years
how would you get two kids without birth
control how would you get kids without
push two kids without pushing off Merit
and two kids or less is a below below
the replace therefore that is what
they're trying to do they're trying to
make us have as few kids as possible in
the name of equality